Sorry,
it's taken me just a little while too.
Good.
Someone says,
well,
I'll,
I'll like go for that.
Let's see.
Um,
hi Jordan.
What are feelings and why do we have the,
well,
here's a way of thinking about it.
So look,
let's say you were walking down a pathway.
I actually saw this happen one day,
so I'll tell you this story.
So I was walking along the cliffs near,
I think it was San Diego or la,
I don't remember.
I think probably,
I think it was,
I think it was San Diego.
Anyways,
I was walking along there
with some friends and uh,
and a brother of a friend of mine who's
quite a toll guys about six foot five,
something like that.
And he was walking along the
path on the edge of the cliff,
kind of sandy and with,
with scrub pine around
overlooking the Pacific Ocean.
And uh,
it was march I think.
So it was warm but not too warm.
We were walking along and all of a sudden
his little girl who I think was like
four or five,
I said she was walking in front of him.
And in front of me and I guess we are
going round a little bit of a corner and
all of a sudden she jumped
right up on his shoulders,
which I'd never seen a child do that.
It was like watching,
you know,
if you,
if a cat's sleep and you
and you and you go out it,
it'll like jump up and puff out
its hair and can jump straight up.
Well that's what this kid did.
And there was a rattlesnake
at the side of the,
of the path.
Now it was cold,
which was probably good.
But you know,
there's a guy named uh,
yeah,
oh I can't read.
He wrote a great book on fear.
It'll come to me,
it'll come to me.
It's a book that I should
have on my book list actually.
And he showed that there
are circuits in your brain.
They're reflex circuits.
So this has been demonstrated to
some degree much earlier that map.
So imagine that a snake is a pattern.
And then imagine that there's a pattern
on your retina that constitutes the
snake.
And then imagine that that can be
transformed into another pattern,
which is a muscular output pattern.
And that muscular output pattern
is to jump you in the air.
So your eyes make your,
your make your muscles
move in a particular way.
And that happens before you see
the snake and before you're afraid.
And the reason for that is that,
so it's there not many neural connections
between snake detection and leaping in
the air.
And that's because if you waited to
feel fear and waited to see the snake,
that would take between a
quarter and half a second,
something like that and the snake
would have already bitten you.
So unless you had those really short
neuropathways that have been conserved in
the evolutionary process since
like the beginning of time,
anything super fast and simple
would be able to kill you.
So now,
so let's say that you do
encounter something unexpected.
Oh first you have these bodily
reflexes that are really fast.
And then the next thing that happens
generally speaking is that you feel an
emotion.
Like maybe you're frozen.
So if you hear a real growl behind you,
you'll freeze.
And then you'll feel fear
and that'll keep you frozen.
And so the,
the fear is,
uh,
an indication of that physiological state.
And then only after that will you
start to think and strategize.
And so you need reactions at multiple
levels of temporal resolution in order to
keep you safe in the world.
And the fast reactions are
muscular and reflexive.
And then the next ones,
generally speaking or something like
emotions and they're low resolution,
but quick,
you know,
like if you're afraid,
it means there's something
that may be dangerous.
It's vague.
And it's not until you explore it that
you know exactly what the danger is.
But the fear is a good
enough initial category.
So you could think about feelings
as instinctual categories,
things to love,
things to eat,
things to run away from,
things to run towards their
low resolution categories.
And that's how animals
categorize the world.
They use emotion and motivation
to categorize the world.
So we have them to keep ourselves properly
oriented in the world and to react
quickly and so that we can stay alive.